I wrote some code to read in the marvel data as a barpartate graph and then to build the character
by character graph and then find the top k strength
and I just reuse the heap code from the last unit to do that.
The new part to focus on is right here. So it goes like this.
What we do is we look through all the different characters in the list of characters
and for each character look at the different books for that character appears
then look at all the characters appearing in those books and for each of those triples, right.
So this is a character, the books for that character and the characters for that book
including the character itself by the way.
It's going to make a link from the first character to the second character.
This make a link. I modified this made link so that if you make a link twice it just keep it count.
And so that's going to keep a measure of the total strength between character one and character two.
Really, if you think about what it's doing here.
It's actually for each pair character one and character two, it's going to add one
each time there's a book they have in common.
Its count up the number of books in common between character one and character two,
which is really just what we wanted, but it's done in terms of a triple nested loop here.
The running time here has to do with the number of edges right.
It's not actually that the product of the nodes times the nodes times the nodes.
Though if it's a completely connected graph it will be, but if it's a sparse graph for each character,
we're only going to list the edges that come out of that.
When I actually execute this, one other things we see is that this computer is faster than my laptop
by about a factor of 2, so it took me 0.5 to read the graph, but anyway, it reached the graph pretty quickly.
It computes all those strengths, which is the part that we're focusing on here
in just a couple of seconds and then it run through the characters
that are connected to other characters and finds the top 10 and I'm not a comic book expert,
but I know enough to actually recognize a couple of the things
that are going on here just the recent movies.
You can see that there a very strong connection between the human torch and the thing.
These are both members of the fantastic four.
I'm going to say half of the members that fit fantastic four.
Here's another one, Mr. Fantastic, and I think the invisible woman is the other one.
What we see here is that books that have the human torch
will often also have the thing in them and so forth.
All the different pairings of the fantastic four end up having very high weight.
They have a lot of books where they all appear together.
Similarly spiderman appears very often with, I'm pretty sure that's his grandmother,
and also with his editor cause Peter Parker is a reporter,
so his editor J. Jonah Jameson shows up in a lot books with him.
Captain America shows up with Tony Stark and I don't think I would know that at all
except there's a current movie out that has them together
and I think it's because they're both Avengers.
They're individual characters but they also appear together often
and I have no idea who Vision and Scarlet Witch are, but I'm sure they're awesome.